do you care that alex jones is going to
join us right now from his bunker studio
to explain why coronavirus is a
globalist hoax would you like to hear
about it okay
all right here he is infowars.com
we have torn down the barricades and
marched past the contact tracer warrior
thesaurus in parking springs
this is victory against the cove 19 hoax
forced inoculation mark of the beast
control system with
5g electromagnetic systems to kill
people if a infowars.com
infowars.com now alex you say you're
going to give us a tour of your bunker i
see you have a lot of products
books different foods
i do i have a jeffrey epstein signed
guitar
over here that's from when i infiltrated
the bilderberg auctions as you know
i have uh 900 danglers from the
promotion of my book alex jones exposes
globus pedophile cults again
and three years of liberty food buckets
powdered eggs powder cookies powdered
cheese
perfect prize for anybody when you're
done with it it doubles as a piss bucket
double value deal
getting it infowars.com 40 off well
you've explained what's going on now in
the world and we understand why you're
upset
listen this is enough your gloveless
trash propaganda i didn't just come here
to tell you this i have a major
announcement to make today the globalist
occultists use the corona hoax to take
our children out of schools we need
now more than ever to educate the youth
on the globalist occultist post-human
agenda
that's why we are launching infowars
jr
jr this is the first anti-globalist
educational entertainment kids network
we got tons of shows for kids you want a
quick preview
sure it's it's
junior with shows like
jeffrey epstein island
hey kids i'm bill clinton
and cartoons whose a pig and her baby
engineered into one
stop humanoid and
slime time it's time to
slime george soros
dump that slime
soros burns that's vitamin slime
good for you
all right so your big announcement is
that uh you have a whole lineup of shows
called
infowars junior for kids to start to
teach them about what's really going on
in the world
anti-deep state control media for kids
did somebody say
kids oh my god
it's the ghost of jeffrey epstein oh my
god
what do you want ghost i want to tell
kids
don't watch info wars junior and don't
take the new turbo force
x3 chewables which are 40 percent off
through the weekend
they are off through the weekend and
don't forget not
only the x3 chewables but you can also
get the triad on pop tarts dna force
junior
and alpha boy vitality b vitamins fish
oil
windex your phones will grow strong as
lead because these products are full of
lead
buy now get a free sorosee babies
coloring book infowars.com please stay
tuned we'll be back right
after these words
[Music]
news today
you